welcome everyone to our last two
sessions of the second day of pi data
global edition my name is jana i'll be
your host today and it's such an honor
to be here in this 2021 edition now i'm
welcoming nils
um he is a machine learning engineering
and current maintainer of flight and
open search ml orchestration tools an
outdoor and maintainer of and data a
data testing tool for data frames
he has a master imported health with a
specialization in social medical science
and public health informatics and prior
to that a background in developmental
biology and immunology
his research interests include
reinforcement learning auto ml creative
machine learning and fairness
accountability and transparency in
automated systems
he enjoys developing open source tools
for improving data science and machine
learning practice and today he is going
to talk us about robust entrant online
machine learning applications with
flight pandera and streamlit
without further ado the connections is
your nails
hi everyone my name is niels
and today i'm super excited to talk to
you about robust and online machine
learning applications
with fly fender and streamline
so before jumping in a little bit of
background um
so
on top of what uh has been introduced
already
um i'm a flightgate maintainer and
author pandora and
i have various background in biology and
public health
uh but now i've sort of
i've sort of gone through a journey in
data science and machine learning and
i guess i've settled on this mission of
making
uh ds and ml practitioners more
productive
so i want to start this talk with a bit
of motivation
behind it
and then dive in
and distinguish between offline and
online machine learning
and then highlight a a particular case
of
online learning which is weather
forecasting um
and then after that i'll
kind of
introduce do a kind of a quick start of
flight pandar and streamlit all of which
are the different projects the different
components
that i'll be putting together
for this particular machine learning
system
uh dive into the pipeline architecture
of the online learning system uh show
you a little demo
of what it looks like in the end and
then give you some takeaways
so uh online i've been seeing this term
full stack data science slash machine
learning engineer
um
and you know when i see this i have to
think to myself what what even is that
you know
so i have to remind myself
you know when i started i was really
obsessed about the algorithms and you
know machine learning training and all
that stuff but
i realized that in in real world ml
systems
um
only a small fraction of that entire
system is ml code and there's a lot of
tools and infrastructure surrounding it
that support it in production
so just to remind you maybe a little
sketch
of what that might look like deploying
models to production you start off
in a research and development phase
collecting data formulating problems
prototyping models and evaluating
in the lab what those models how those
models perform
and if you're lucky enough and if you
can prove or justify to yourself that
the models should be released production
then you might work with a devops or ml
ups as maybe it's been
branded these days you might work with a
devops person to deploy the model work
with a front-end engineer to build a ui
you deploy it and then your end users
you know be they internal or external to
your your organization
use that ui and then you can use you
know if you put the right
instrumentation in you can use whatever
that interaction looks like to evaluate
models
and then of course there's the endless
iteration cycle between rnd and
production
so to begin this presentation i want to
start with this question of how far can
a small data team get
building and shipping production model
driven data products
and at least in my experience this is
oftentimes a small team like one or two
people and
if you're lucky more with particular
specializations
and on top of this i gave myself this
challenge of building an online learning
system that updates a model hourly and
then displays forecasts on a web ui
and i want to focus on online learning
because it forces the practitioner
to think about how to manage incremental
data acquisition
how to manage model updates in
production as a first class citizen how
to think about it in that way
and then how to evaluate models
where the model only sees each example
once
so i have accepted this challenge and
i'll
there for the rest of this talk i'll
show you what the results are of this
sort of exploration
but before that
just a little crash course on offline
versus online just so everyone is
literally a single slide so
offline learning is otherwise known as
batch learning so you have a static
training data set
you train a model on that potentially
with multiple passes through it
and then you deploy it uh if even and
you might refresh that data set and
retrain and so you know
it's up to you how often you do that
whereas with online learning
it's kind of like the default setting is
that you're getting data in
[Music]
at some
relatively fast frequency and i guess
that that also depends on the on the use
case but
generally the the model only sees
train each training instance once in
some temporal fashion
and so why you know what are some of the
reasons why online learning would be
deployed so
so if your data isn't static like by
definition your data isn't static it's
generated as a function of time
or
if your data might be too large to
practically store or train a model all
at once on you might want to use online
learning
other reasons is if you just
fundamentally can't assume iid data so
like today's temperature depends on
yesterday's temperature
or if your model needs to be up to date
as possible as up to date as possible
due to the dynamic nature of the data so
all of these points are kind of
interrelated
so the use case i want to focus on is
weather forecasting in particular hourly
temperature forecasts and we'll be
getting our data from the national
oceanic and atmospheric administration
using the integrated surface data set
isd
which is
various weather related metrics like
temperature dewpoint c level pressure
things like that collected
at an hourly
resolution but the data doesn't
necessarily isn't necessarily like
updated in real time so there is some
cadence with which these data are
updated and the way you interact with
this data is you make an api request to
the the noaa abi
endpoint
the query or the the request might look
like this
you get a json response and part of that
response is metadata pointing to files
containing the actual data you want
so once you have that you you you
request one of these csv files
and you get the raw data in this format
csv file and in this case uh we're
focusing on this temperature column
which is itself a string that you need
to parse and that was one of the
challenges
or one of the points i wanted to
challenge myself with is there are
various weather apis out there with
clean data but you know i wanted data in
a fairly raw format
so now we have the data out of the way
we'll just use a very very like simple
autoregressive model so this is
basically linear regression
um
where you predict
the
scalar value you know temperature in
this case at time t
based on
some bias
and some coefficient some linear
combination of the
previous time steps
with of course the irreducible error
for full transparency i actually uh
included additional features
which are one hot encoded time based
features so day of week month month of
year et cetera
just to give the model a little more
context
and the evaluation metric i use is
similarly naive maybe
i'm not like a time series an analytics
expert so maybe some of you might
be able to point out better metrics for
this but i chose exponentially weighted
mean of the absolute error and then this
way since we have an online learning
system we can similarly evaluate our
model in an online fashion
so this is a kind of cartoon sketch high
level overview of the pipeline
in the
this kind of empty gray box is
the pipeline that's going to do our
computation all the heavy lifting which
is going to be done by flight which is
an orchestration and execution engine
and sandwiched between this
clean raw data you see these two green
boxes um these are meant to represent
the pandara schemas and i'll show you
what that exactly looks like later but
these are meant to
um ensure that the data quality of data
coming in from the external source in
this case the noaa.com api
is in the expected format and then once
we've cleaned and parsed the data
it's it comes out in the expected format
that we need for training
um after we prepare the data we update
the model to the latest time step the
latest available time step get the
forecast
um and then our streamlet web ui will
read that output to display it to us
so before diving deeper into the exact
pipeline i need to
just briefly introduce these three
technologies starting with flight
so flight flight is like the
stratosphere it has many layers and it
can mean many different things to many
people so
if you're an infrastructure person maybe
it's a kubernetes first workflow
orchestration engine which it is
or if you're a data engineer maybe it's
you can see it as an automated data
lineage
tracking platform
but as an ml engineer i'm i particularly
am interested in it because
is it's a typesafe data pipeline
language
and so you write tasks which are
isolated pieces of data processing or
computation
and here we're using flight kit which is
the python sdk for flight
and here we're decorating our two
functions with the add test decorator
and what that does is it
you can think of it as a docker
container that wraps all that code and
then runs it somewhere in some arbitrary
to be determined location
here we're just transforming data and
aggregating it so like a simple toy
example
and then you can compose workflows
together uh compose workflows by
connecting tasks together and so this
looks like python but it's actually a
dsl where
this function body is compiled and into
a protobuf format that flight can reason
about and all the types
are important in that flight can analyze
them and tell you beforehand at compile
time whether your workflow is going to
work or not whether it thinks it's going
to work or not
so you can all the code you saw above
you can develop and execute locally but
then once you want to deploy and scale
it you send it over to a flight backend
so you you give it your compiled
workflow and some config
and flight is this abstraction layer
that
schedules and figures out
where when and how to run it on a
kubernetes cluster
flight isn't doesn't exist in isolation
you can use
a whole suite of integrated
tools
including spark pi torch tensorflow cube
flow
and this brings me to pandara um so when
i joined the union ai team i integrated
pandera
which was a perfect fit because
it is a basically a data frame typing
library and so when
um
typing started emerging in python as a
this gradual typing approach
i was interested in
like answering the question scratching
this itch of i i really want to type my
data frames because they're like these
complex black boxes of
just data that i don't know what is in
there so
pandara
essentially adds guardrails to your
pipeline so if your pipeline is this
suspension bridge
data frames are the people traveling
through it
it helps you
it helps them not fall off and break
your your code
so
henders started off as a pandas data
frame library but as it gained adoption
um
i saw the need for expanding it to other
data frame frameworks
and so coming in the next release is i'm
happy to announce that we'll be adding
support for das moden and koalas
and um there are so many other libraries
emerging libraries out there that um
the next piece of work to do is to
support uh ex like an easy way of
extending it to other non-pandas
compliant libraries
so with pender you can encode in some
assumptions about data frames as schemas
and so this might look like data classes
a little bit or pedantic if you're
familiar with that
and schema inheritance is followed here
in that you can inherit from other
schema models and the fields that are
defined in the inherited the parent
classes will be present in the child
classes
pandara also supports indexes and regex
column matching so if you have fields or
columns that are logically grouped
together with the same validation rules
you can make very concise schemas
you can also extend pandar's built-in
validation checks so this is
checking if
the field is greater or equal to zero
and custom checks are super easy
it's just a method in the class
it's also super easy to integrate with
flight kit
uh you just have to install this plugin
and any ad task decorated function will
at runtime
check the inputs and outputs of
data frame schemas
defined with pendant or pender
and then if something goes wrong
you get informative errors so if a
column is not present in the data frame
it complains
or if a column has an unexpected data
type
or if your assumptions in this game are
violated are violated so like here
there's the presence of negative numbers
and odd numbers and
um if you provide this lazy equals true
parameter
you see that this failure cases data
frame inside
this schema errors object
provides all of the failure cases that
caused the error so it makes it super
inspectable
what exactly went wrong
and then last but not least there's
streamlit which is a you know delight to
use it's basically
uh a way of making interactive uis via
scripting so
here's the hello world app
you run streamlet run
myapp.pi and then you get a nice
beautiful web app for you to interact
with
streamlid and flight work well together
so flight has this notion of a client
called flight remote and you can use
this remote object to get
executions workflow inputs and outputs
task definitions
anything like that
and you can then grab that data and
display it on a streamlit app
okay so this is maybe the most the the
next few sides are the most involved um
so
i'll just remind you of this high level
overview the actual pipeline at the end
doesn't quite look like this
and that's because i
set forth certain requirements when
doing this project
so the first one is that it needs to
support incremental model updates and
pre-training
the second is that
i don't want to waste request fetching
data from
the noaa api
and the last is i want to implement
online evaluation metrics which i hinted
at before
so this is it's a little more busy but
um i'll talk you through it basically
the inputs of the to the flight workflow
is this genesis date time
which is when the first
ever run of this work this model will
occur and then a target date time which
is greater or equal to the genesis date
time so this is the thing that when you
schedule this job to run if say every
hour
this is a thing that increments
you have a look back window which just
tells you okay how many time steps back
in this case at an hourly resolution
does your model have access to to make
the next uh forecast
and then how many days of pre-training
do you want when you initialize your
model at the genesis date time
so
the neat trick that's happening here
you'll notice is that here's the get
latest model workflow
and then here's the get latest model
workflow here but with the previous
timestamp
so the mind-blowing thing here is that
flight
supports recursion
and what that enables
is i can
be very efficient about how i run my
workflow so
when i first run this workflow
i'm going to initialize my model so
that's that's all fine and good but once
target daytime is greater than genesis
time
i'm going to try to get the latest model
from the previous time step
which in this in the second run will be
just this initialized model so it's you
know recursion always kind of
uh boggles my mind a little bit but when
you grasp it
this basically is it's cached so this
little this little icon here means that
the outputs
of each of these
pieces of computation are cached and so
it doesn't re-run that computation it
just grabs the latest model and then
updates it
and then from there we get our forecasts
and our metrics and then we plug that
into streamline
but where's the data coming from so this
doesn't mention anything about the data
well
we need to zoom in to initialize model
and update model so within this
workflow
we're initializing the model and metrics
but then we're also getting a
the training instances and caching that
within this workflow
and same goes for update model
and this way we're kind of creating kind
of it's not a feature store but it's
kind of like a feature or a training
data cache
where if we want to reproduce this
model and reproduce this run all we have
to do is provide the same exact
parameters and we'll be able to recover
the exact same model
um
with a caveat of if the node.gov api has
somehow been updated then it won't
exactly be the same
and then finally with the model
evaluation piece um
[Music]
we want to compute
training and
validation error
in an online fashion so this is kind of
pseudo code that does this
so basically before we update the model
at any given timestamp we feed
we do like a we make a prediction given
that model
and since the model hasn't been trained
on it yet this is validation error right
then we update the model here
and then boom right in the same
place we're gonna
feed
these the same training instance but now
that it's seen it it's technically uh
the training error
so in this way we can
in a single you know in a with a single
piece of uh single pass through the same
a single training instance
we can compute a running
validation and training error
and then finally really quick i just
want to show you what this looks like
when we connect it all together so
you can actually go to this
bitly link
the presentation slides will let you get
here really quickly but
just want to show you the interactive
element here of i've pre
uh pre-run a bunch of different
[Music]
workflows for different locations
different cities and these these happen
to be cities where uh union ai team
members reside so they can use this to
make uh clothing decisions uh based on
the temperature forecast at their risk
but as you can see from the model
metadata um the model is not great so
the model is uh
may mean absolute error exponentially
weighted is like
seven degrees celsius off which is
pretty bad
but that said you know this is this is
where you iterate on that one piece of
the ml system right
and then finally i just want to show you
the flight console so this
this is literally all the executions for
all the different workflows so here's
the seattle workflow
here's the green bay wisconsin workflow
and here you can see
you can go in you can look at the
execution graph it looks sort of like
the graph i showed you before
you can inspect the inputs and outputs
of each of the nodes in this graph
so it's really quite easy to audit you
know what exactly went wrong if one of
these pieces failed
jumping back here
i'd like to conclude
um so
you know this is fairly obvious but i
think it's it we should move towards
full stack data science and law
engineering teams and not
individual people
although you might find yourself in that
situation
um and i want to uh just emphasize that
i presented to you three tools that lets
you execute and orchestrate computation
and scale it
um
add type with flight
and then add type safety to your data
frames or data frame like objects with
pandera
and then finally make
really
nice interactive uis with streamline
and with that i
will open it up to questions
i'm happy to answer any questions
you have here's my contact and a bunch
of links
to the you know weather forecasting app
the repo
and the three projects that i
showed you today
thank you
thank you
thank you so much
and we have some questions actually let
me read for you
alexander is asking what are the
difference between flight and cloud
composer
oh i'm not super familiar with cloud
composer so i i am aware that there are
a lot of
dag based
ml or data processing ml orchestration
tools out there
um i know somewhere we've we've done a
comparison there's i think there's a
blog or we're working on a blog i
but sorry i i'm not i'm not
knowledgeable about um enough about a
cloud composer to answer
i think so yeah
of course always you can move to the
talk to continue more discussions but
yes
um ali or ali sorry if i pronounce my
name
is asking what is the main difference
between flight and air flow
this i can say a little bit more about
so the history of flight is that it was
started at lyft
and actually the team that built flight
initially built it on top of airflow
um
and i need to like you know
get my story straight here but
like essentially they found certain
requirements that they had it with that
was not fulfilled by airflow i need to i
can get back to you um ali about that
what those specific needs were
but they determined that okay we're
gonna go to
we'll have dockerized tasks and
orchestrate it with kubernetes
and i haven't used airflow before but
i'm not sure if the back end of that is
kubernetes um you can correct me if i'm
wrong
um
but that that's the main differentiator
of flight it is is that it's um
kubernetes first and so it's basically
an abstraction layer
on top of kubernetes
that you know abstracts away a lot of
things that a lot of configuration a lot
of like scheduling things like that and
adds a few more little pieces of
functionality that kubernetes does not
offer
okay thank you
alex is pandera like pike uh i'm not
sure panderic or panda dick or pandemic
but for data frames
yeah yes exactly so
i think the two projects i think
pedentic is slightly older than pandara
um but that's that's pretty much exactly
right so pandora's
original syntax which is still supported
is more like object it's like a
dictionary of column keys and columns
um but then a contributor made a
pedantic like interface so now it looks
very much like pedantic and then
actually the next release
it's going to be
a valid
pedantic type so you can use it in your
pedantic models
yeah
okay and i will finish with this just
because they are they are um
to alex
yeah yes from alex to what extent is
flight a perfect alternative
yeah so prefect we are very much aware
of prefect um
so i
you know i need to
again educate myself more about this but
uh
i think from my understanding prefix
back end is desk
and a flight's back end is kubernetes
so in a sense
and and flight is is built to be
language agnostic so the contain if your
container contains any language's code
like c or r or julia
you could use the python sdk and you
know point to that image and give it
some inputs and it would work in your
workflow so
flight is is
um
if your team or if you are you are
familiar with kubernetes and you want to
take advantage of that
then um
flight sort of the flight is the logical
choice
um
but i don't know too much about prefect
and the advantages of prefect so
um i'd be curious to learn more though
okay thank you very much we have still
like uh three more questions
so kindly invite you to go to the box
channel
i will stop the record and thank you
again so much for this nice presentation
thank you
you